думаю що нашим глядачам і нашим виборцям
буде цікаво дослухати що перетворюється
і Як створюються нова схема мега
корупції забрали 500 тисяч гектарів
землі передали як в тимчасове управління
фонду держмайна Фонд держмайна далі
передається цю землю всі 500 тисяч плюс
користування на 50 років новоствореному
державному підприємству чи це буде одне
чи їх буде 12 чи 24 це ще невідомо
сказали і подумають над цим
12%. це державне підприємство заплатить
в бюджет а 12 залишає в своєму
розпорядженні вам не соромно Влада ви
уже ніяк не зупинитися в розкраданні на
зерновому коридорі вас півтора відсотки
з обороту тут у вас буде 12%. я
порахувала це десь біля 5 мільярдів за
рік буде накопичено в кармані корупція
під час війни сягнула більшість розмірів
Чим там при тих
документах які зараз десь знаходяться
далеко в Російській Федерації коли
державне підприємство яке заволодіє 500
+ 1000 гектарами землі здасть в оренду в
суборенду реальному там бізнесу хто
зможе заплатити 24%. то в бюджет воно
буде платити тільки 12 Бо це буде
орендна плата послуга не земельний
податок якби хотіли наповнити бюджет то
передавали би тим хто готов платити
24%, не як субаренду а оренду від фонду
держмайна і тоді всі би гроші пішли в
державний бюджет А так державне
підприємство чи сітка таких державних
підприємств буде головними спонсорами на
виборчу кампанію всієї цієї братії яка
хоче йти двома-трьома флангами І знову
мати владу Майте відповідальність перед
тими людьми хто воює хто втратив
здоров'я Хто взагалі залишає життя на
полі бою за те щоб ми з вами тут
обговорювали